[Music]
so
whereas it is pleased almighty god
to call to his mercy
our late sovereign lady
queen elizabeth ii
of blessed and glorious memory
by whose decease
the crown of the united kingdom of great
britain and northern ireland
is solely and rightfully
come to the prince charles philip arthur
george
we therefore the lord spiritual and
temporal of this realm
and members of the house of commons
together with other members of her late
majesty's privy council
and representatives of the realms and
territories
aldermen and citizens of london and
others
do now hereby
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland and of his other realms and
territories king
head of the commonwealth defender of the
faith
to whom we to acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching god
by whom kings and queens do reign
to bless his majesty with long and happy
years to reign over us
given its in james's palace this 10th
day of september
in the year of our lord
2022
the captain of the kingsguard will now
order the troops
to present arms and the color will be
lowered
[Music]
and then god save the king
god save the king
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
to a great cheer the captain
of the guard brings
the troops out of the present
and they will now ground their arms
place their rifles on the ground and
prepare to give three cheers
they kneel down place their
rifles and return
so with joy wherever you are
if you wish join in with three cheers
for the new king
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
captain of the king's guard will now
start placing a headdress the recovery
of the arms
and
got a king of arms the kings of arms the
heralds perseverance of the college of
arms will
then along with the herald's
extraordinary
leave from the balcony
and the principal proclamation of the
new reign
is done
we wait to find out the date
of
the state funeral of the late queen
which will be announced later but
the nation in mourning has raised its
head and will in the proclamations that
take place across the united kingdom
might
see in edinburgh
the guns are firing in salute
to the proclamation having been made
and having completed that gun salute
they fall out as the
heralds and kings return
into st james's palace
fishing
so
the state trumpeters the last to leave
from the balcony
meanwhile
the coal stream guards who formed the
kingsguard at the moment on the royal
palaces who have turned out for this
moment
formed back into position the cold
stream guards band
who played for the first formal
[Music]
playing of the national anthem to god
save the king
and they prepare to march
[Applause]
they're saluting the color off the
parade ground here in frowry court the
color which has been carried and
lowered in salute was also
adorned with two black morning
bands and also
a wreath to mark that this is the
anniversary
of a battle honor
for the king's guard
[Music]
the city of london
21 for the tower and an extra 20 because
it's a royal fortress
and the
honorable artillery the oldest
regiment in the british army they're
firing the remnant of those shots from
the gun salute as the king's guard
returned to their duties
protecting buckingham palace
and james's parents
and in hyde park too the
king's troop royal horse artillery
continued
[Music]
changed the name of the king's troop
it had been the riding troop
on the queen's accession she wanted to
respect my father
by keeping the name the king's troops
throughout her reign and now of course
the title makes sense with the new king
goldstring god's band return
to the god room here at james's palace
[Music]